welcome to GameSpot's coverage of the
electronic triple 2016 how you doing
luck is it a game on stage brought to
you by airheads I'm Daniel Dwyer joined
by mr. Michael mehar d and is astounding
chin chin wags yes your you are the
chilliest of them all and grand growing
from Telltale Games thank you so much
for coming on to talk to us about star
wars the force awakens it's absolutely
my pleasure the way here actually okay
we get this because I used to work in in
gamestop right and I used to love the
names of these games could you ever like
the longest ones to get into the
computer there was a lego star wars the
force awakens the video game I don't if
we all the video game okay lego star
wars the force awakens people know what
lego star wars is yeah yeah absolutely
everyone's trying to make Star Wars
games now you've got Vince Zampella
trying to make a strut all you know all
these exercises Creed notch are the
people doing but you guys r OG you've
been doing this for yeah like this over
11 years now right so so yeah we have we
have a history there with you know Lucas
arts which is ice because it means that
they we could we get to tell new stories
as well as tell the story of the movie
which right which is also and that's
your role right a telltale yeah yeah
we're travelers tales I should point out
we don't get told to God I did do
another it's fine it's fine because
they're still be there are still things
that we are credited on mobygames as big
joke sorry Mary they still haven't fixed
it [ __ ] yeah yeah so I write the
dialogue basically I right daph jokes
for kids which is which is what I can do
because I'm an idiot so I'm perfectly
suited to do then how long have you been
doing it at travelers tales um I've been
doing it all got about seven years lego
city undercover was my first one I
wonderful yeah we've actually got the
game running right here yeah yeah he's
off-screen playing yeah Jay need and who
is my boss far more photogenic than me
but a very modest man so I didn't want
to appear on stage but he's a he's
playing through here at the moment and
this is one of our new adventure levels
which kind of feeds into the start of
the movie and in this one your pains poe
dameron and you are rescuing admiral
ackbar from the finalizer okay and yeah
so if you want to start running around
and this shows off quite this level kind
of art shows up all of our new features
we have these sleep or multi builds
whereby [ __ ] previous Lego games you
have the same pile of bricks and you'd
always build the same thing with it yeah
but now you can use a pile of bricks to
build multiple different options and
sometimes it's just for like a city
little joke
case you've got two different ways of
getting rid of a dyin ogre all right
another ones that you'll have like
little puzzles so it's nice it means
that when you replay the level you are
always seeing something new which is not
so yeah we really try to push things
forward with this going yeah I mean that
I guess that's a sort of double edged
sword of being as successful as you guys
r is that like during we have played
lots of sorrow Lego X Games year act at
this stage we played a lot of lego star
wars game yeah so yeah you need to sort
of I guess retain what made those games
so successful that also canceled flares
in there yeah I always increase the
amount of characters you can unlock
because it's like 200 plus this time
it's not really yeah yeah plus this but
this is the first dogs game where we've
actually got dialogue right because
they're the previous one didn't have
that and so this one and we've also had
the cast come back and record new lines
like Harrison's all came back and was
Han Solo for us did you get to write
dialogue yeah I've written dialogue for
Han Solo Greg Grunberg who place
networks Lee even came by the stand and
played with himself apartment right on
their forest which was which is awesome
as well but yeah yeah like everyone came
back it's yeah it's amazing that's
wonderful Mike you played a bunch of the
star wars lego star wars games yeah
heavy was the original saga when they
released up with opposite yeah yeah yeah
I've played that a lot I mean I've
played a lot of travelers tales I think
Marvel is my favorite one right but I'm
excited for this just because I haven't
really played any force awakens in
videogame form yet right that's actually
a good point benelux is the first one
right well I mean there's a little bit i
think in a rival product but yeah well i
mean we're the only ones you're telling
like the full story yeah then these
extra stories as well so it's kind of
you get your full fix with that except
in dark lego form so it's going to
explode
it's the best of both worlds yeah how
close are you sticking to the story
meaning is usually pretty true the story
but are you adding in anything what we
got the new adventure level in terms of
like telling the story of the movie we
we stay pretty close obviously you have
to take certain license like there's a
family reunion in the movie which
doesn't go that well right and obviously
that's quite a dark moment but we have
to adapt that so that kids are terrified
out of their skins yes um so we you know
we have a bit of fun with that but yeah
like I said we have these new adventure
levels which are all sort of leading up
to the start the movie and we came up
with those are in conjunction with
lucasarts so ya head of that process go
cuz you're basically filling in Canon
what the canon I would i don't i'm not
sure if it's kind of like I hear one
thing here another I where I say is if
you've seen the movie there aren't tiny
little Lego dudes in it so I don't know
how I got rooked point right i mean from
some of the drawings and for her but sir
but you know you totally came up with
with them I mean it was kind of you know
with website what happened here or there
tell us all here's a story event that
you can you can fill in and then we'd
sort of crash back and forth design
document and then I'd come along and
ride at load of idiotic jokes about yeah
so yeah it was it was totally you know
in concert with them
I'm guessing as this is a lego star wars
game that large sort of focuses would
put on playing cooperatively with people
as well oh yeah if you play all that
sort of stuff oh yeah yeah so you know
hot you got some 2 player you know local
multiplayer and there's also things like
because it's a star wars game we got
these blaster battles in it which we
never done before where you totally have
those you know you know the gun fights
with the lasers and the pew pew pew down
the corridor we totally have that in
there you're hung currents are currently
take shots and you lean out and stuff
and we also like a flight gameplay is
way better like our dog fights in space
which right you have later in this demo
are so much better than we've done
before we've really just like up the
ante on everything so let's actually
focus on the demo because this is what
everyone is looking at the moment by the
way if you have any questions at all in
the chat and let me know if they're in
the game spot shot or on the twitter
shot i'm keeping our eye on both of them
yeah so what's what's going on here
there's a I love the water effects in
this it looks like i'm getting my toys
dirty every time he walks into that slot
well you know as it stars we've ended up
in a trash compactor and so after a
couple of failed attempts were actually
we're trying to make our way up to this
this exit this at the the back of the
room here with help of all of our
characters and in this case we've
actually built another one of these
multi bill dimensions in this case we
need to get to c-3po up to a little
control at the back so we're using these
these pile of Lego bricks to build a
lift here to get him up and then we can
smash those those bricks apart and use
the same ones to build another part
right the puzzle and we have a bunch of
those in the game and and you know if
you get it wrong then the characters
will kind of talk to you and go oh maybe
I need to build this first so it kind of
direct you towards the right solution
and then once we get c-3po up there
he'll do it like a little mini game and
we'll get into our space flight at some
of the folks in the chat asking which
version this is this is a good place
aphorism yeah this is pierced or this is
running off actually this is maybe one
of the most fun things i love doing your
especially when your games comes on what
platforms is this game called you know
everything like a toaster ovens you know
it's every year its peers for asexuals
one is xbox 360 ps3 it's where you it's
PC it's three years and it's perfect wow
that's one
so no PSP version is there no I think we
have dropped support for that I'd have
to check to be perfectly honest but I'm
fairly sure we have good stuff actually
does the Vita version have like the
voice acting in yeah yeah absolutely
yeah yeah that's it we try and we try
and get as much into all of our versions
as we can yeah cuz you know cost a bit
to a higher those actors so right you
don't want to not put them in every
single version of the stairs always been
great as actually like releasing on
those consoles and some of which like
I'm a PS vita owner and there's some
good games to come a debate severed last
week with yeah often sort of underserved
markets 30 yeah yeah but you know a load
of people love playing we've always had
it's always lovely getting letters from
the fans and loads of them they do play
them on those those plans those are the
only ones they actually played The
Motley so yeah we we like to absolutely
serve those people so what's kicking off
here so yeah we've managed to escape
from the finalized that but we're gonna
have a bunch of TIE fighters are so
we're gonna try and lose them in an
asteroid field because and you know it
won't be an asteroid field without
someone telling us about the odds of
jetan an asteroid Ackbar in a Jedi
Starfighter yes yes a Buddhist out like
a bunch of like creatures from the
extended universe and things like that
which is cool but they're so we have
these like these on rail segments which
are just please you know like candy
filled rushes of explosions and stuff
like that but then we also have these
bits where opens up and you have like
complete control over your your ship and
you can like barrel roll and do
loop-de-loops if you get an eye on your
tail is it a real barrel roll or is it
what we call a barrel it's not really
about okay well you're gonna have to
tell me what the difference doing that
thing yeah yeah a barrel voice I know
about that one oh okay right it's not a
barrel well then what is that thing I
don't know nothing it's gotta weigh less
like a corkscrew yeah yeah more boring
name they see a speedy be sick in the
cockpit moon yeah Mexican asada is well
we have we have you know spinny be sick
in the cockpit as a feature and I go so
yeah we're flying into this this
asteroid which is full of other these
dues creatures and we're going to use to
basically mask our escape in the first
order here okay stop asking me why do
you think I I've had an absolute blast
playing like d these the shooter
sections of the game I think I
I've been doing lega shuffles that would
be totally awesome because I think
tickets it's really really good it feels
really great I'm with slight surprise I
should be surprising that you know I
work with competent people but but it's
like really good I mean I it's really
wonderful how well it works out and even
like the bits where you know your
control they're really cool I got a
bunch of questions governor okay Ben
Leslie five asking is the PS Vita 3ds
versions different gameplay wise to the
console version a little bit different
yeah in terms of the amount that's in
there like I mean tells the whole movie
but I think there's slightly fewer in
the way their new adventure lovers that
feed into it but you know in terms of
the actual the level designs that
they're pretty much identical and also
folks asking how sort of either like
open-world e-type section yeah yeah we
have we have these hub levels as you
play through the story you'll normally
your playthrough or hub and and then you
can revisit the upside like you got the
car resistance trace you got the inside
of the Millennium Falcon the Starkiller
jakku and tak adonna khare oil that you
can learn explore there's loads of
little silly side missions in there you
can unlock and then they give you the
gold bricks that allow you to unlock the
the new adventure levels right okay so
that's how you get to access it yeah
yeah so that they unlock ah but then you
have to pay a bunch of gold bricks to
actually play them hello awesome to get
the pick and choose it when you want to
do next yeah yeah so what's good what's
going on here just so here of a battle
here we're going to knock out a bunch of
the the TIE fighters around and then the
Special Forces type r is going to appear
and they've got these torpedoes behind
them and we can use those to destroy
these blockages are being seeded little
crystal is the these these blockages
with purple crystals in them and that's
going to release a bunch of aliens into
the play field and the ideas were trying
to create enough chaos that we can
escape in that chaos so what James gonna
do is hopefully shoots on these Thai
fighters and then snapple the sweet
sweet to put torpedoes that they drop
and then you can use those to blow open
these things and you seem like the pink
carriers are basically pointing to you
or to these targets even this looks a
little more open than you know like that
my section of rail oh yeah and this kind
of reflects those hub worlds in the
power yeah and we took that we tell you
have a whole bunch of these like this
this one where you're escaping the
finalizer early on and you can
you can like fly between the decks of
the vine lights and stun like that it's
like we built this really big model of
it and just shoot with the gun turrets
on it and create all this mayhem yeah
that they're they're really good I can't
overstate it they're really great these
seconds there was a one of the wonderful
things about this series has always been
that you're able to play as like so many
different characters he asked the main
ones either so in the force awakens
obviously there are you know a host of
cracking people really love there's a
host of like sort of sideline characters
as well how many of these can you is
there anyone you miss like um do you
know I mean if I say no then someone
will go well there was there was a
muppet left of camera at one point we
did but yeah I said this 200 plus and I
mean that's not just from this movie
there's some from you know the previous
movies and like clone wars and stuff
like that but yeah I mean we even have
some sort of adventures with them like
this is described to the Crimson corsair
who's in one scene it's the guy who Finn
is going to leave with and we have an
advisor where he basically steals the
ship that you use at the start of this
mission in order to infiltrate the
finalizer so yeah we trying to really
serve that and you know you can go and
unlock them and play them and mix and
match the parts of them but yeah
basically if they were on screen for
about five seconds in the movie than
chances are we've got a LEGO version of
them like you can you think of any
people because ask him I'm taking over
the shop Simon takes character the
shopkeeper oh yeah uncle plot and yeah
yeah and he's being voiced by simon pegg
so really you got help for something
yeah yeah give a Daniel Craig
stormtrooper uh we do have him yeah we
do have them we have a level where
you're controlling him and Ray basically
escaping oh yeah yeah yeah Oh Craig a
strong yeah he's the one that she does
the first my trick on No yeah oh yeah
he's not voicing him and out of you say
your rooms get out of hand you're
probably you can probably just say yeah
we have them and I would see a
stormtrooper hear the voice I guess
that's doing that case yes you did come
back yeah you heard of here well that's
excellent that's it that's the demo
doors over yeah we're just going to talk
awkwardly over this screen now that's
great with your out like real soon oh
yeah jun 28 thanks for that by the way
usually 83 it's like great thanks for
coming on and see your game at e3 next
year yeah when we learn outs the deck
wedding
yeah but yeah you guys are out in a
fortnight or so right yeah yeah jun 28
on everything yeah so presumably it's
finished i hope so i'll have to the
phone the office in check awesome do you
guys do anything LC at all with this
stuff yeah we got these are these really
cool extra adventure levels that kind of
sort of span off from the main narrative
like got one where there's a couple of
pilots who basically crash and star
clear and they have to get across the
Starkiller to escape the planet before
it explodes and yeah a bunch of others
it's really cool stuff good stuff
alright crane before we send you on your
way what is when is it out and my
platforms yeah I literally I don't even
ask the city animals down was I just
June twenty-eighth on everything uh you
know xbox 360 xbox one ps3 ps4 were you
pc 3d s and PS vita awesome grain from
travelers tales thank you so much for
coming on thank you for inviting me and
thank you very much to Jamie for putting
on a wonderful display and look like
that really well all right we'll we'll
be back in in a couple of minutes folks
we've got hit man episode for coming on
next we're going to talk about South
Park the fractured butthole that David
cage is going on to talk about Detroit
become human apparently the wild hunt is
going to be on stage while we play some
Guenter Penny's going to be playing Gwen
to kingdom come deliverance that really
exciting Kickstarter at a pride ego
fight vr from Ubisoft mr. Schaeffer is
coming on to tell us all about why we
should play psychonauts in Virtual
Reality plus god of war at the end of
the show loads of stuff right here on
the game spot stage so don't go anywhere
if you back in a couple of minutes
you're watching the game spot stage
brought to you by airheads